Jean-Marc blancovici bonjour les
lecteurs de Marianne les internautes de
Marianne vous connaissent absolument
tous mais on va quand même dire que vous
êtes président du chiffre project et
surtout que vos positions ces derniers
temps sur l'écologie et la façon de
répondre à l'urgence climatique disons
provoque des sursauts parfois même plus
on va y revenir
[Musique]
une proposition que vous avez faite sur
les voyages en avion l'idée de limiter
les voyages en avion et je peux même
vous citer je suis favorable à un modèle
communiste riche ou pauvre vous avez
droit à trois ou quatre vols dans votre
vie dont deux dans votre jeunesse
c'était sur France Inter et ça
suscité mais alors mais une colère
est-ce qu'on peut revenir sur cette
proposition d'abord et ensuite on
parlera de ce que ça suscite et de ce
que ça révèle de l'état du débat
écologique cette proposition vous la
voyez comment je vois le côté
provocateur du terme communiste mais
concrètement on fait quoi alors en fait
au début c'est pas une proposition c'est
le résultat d'un petit calcul
Léa Salamé m'avait posé la question
alors je me rappelle plus exactement du
libellé mais j'aurais dû réviser avant
de venir ici mais c'était en gros c'est
quoi le nombre de vols dans une vie qui
est compatible avec le respect de
l'accord de Paris ou un truc dans ce
genre là alors j'ai fait une petite
règle de trois j'ai dit bah très bien on
va imaginer que chaque terrien est le
même droit à voler dans sa vie donc vous
soyez somalien brésilien indien ou
français c'est pareil et on va regarder
le nombre de vols global que l'aviation
peut se permettre dans un monde
fortement décarboné on est entre le
cinquième et le dixième de ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui parce que les carburantes
substitution on y ramènera peut-être
quand on fait les quand on fait les
calculs quand on fait les maths comme
disent les Anglais
on se rend compte que le compte ne sera
pas
et donc si on doit répartir
équitablement entre tous les Terriens un
volume de vol en avion qui est de
l'ordre du cinquième ou du dixième de ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui ce qui fait encore
énormément par rapport à ce qu'on avait
dans les années 50 il faut bien voir et
bien on se retrouve avec quatre vols
dans une vie par terrien voilà donc
c'est le résultat à l'origine d'une
règle de trois c'est pas vraiment une
proposition c'est à dire que je suis pas
venu avec un dossier dans lequel j'ai
déjà la loi le décret d'application etc
c'est pas du tout ça c'est un calcul que
j'ai fait à la volée alors en fait elle
m'a posé la question une première fois à
ce moment je me suis dit l'ordre de
grandeur doit être à peu près celui-là
parce que je me rappelle très bien avoir
précisé ces quatre c'est peut-être 6 etc
et puis quand on est consultant on se
refait pas donc rentrez chez moi j'ai
pris ma feuille excel j'ai fait ma
petite règle de trois et je suis arrivé
effectivement avec quelque chose qui est
de l'ordre de 4 et j'ai publié il y a
quelques semaines sur Linkedin le
résultat de marque de Troie voilà
comment j'ai calculé voilà etc donc elle
est revenue là-dessus une deuxième fois
où je suis passé sur France Inter parce
que vous confirmez oui j'ai déjà là j'ai
fait le calcul donc là je peux vous dire
c'est 4 voilà c'est alors est-ce que ça
veut dire que j'ai une proposition
opérationnelle non
mais c'est exactement comme les deux
tonnes vous savez maintenant un certain
nombre de gens connaissent cette valeur
de l'empreinte carbone qui doit être
amené à deux tonnes par personne d'ici à
2050 alors qu'aujourd'hui elle est à peu
près à 10 par français parlent de tonnes
équivalent CO2 c'est-à-dire les
émissions gaz à effet de serre qui sont
là contrepartie de tout ce qu'on
consomme nos vêtements notre nourriture
notre logement notre mobilité etc tout
les services publics et ça doit donc
être divisé par 5 d'ici à 2050 sachant
que nous sommes en 2023 en fait quand
vous regardez le résultat de ce calcul
il est tout aussi révolutionnaire que ma
proposition de 4 volts
alors je suis tout à fait d'accord là je
pense que alors ça faisait très
longtemps que j'avais pas vu des
réactions aussi violentes j'ai quand
même reçu quelques mails où je me suis
fait traiter de connard et d’abrutis
littéralement oui mais ça c'est assez
classique de la part de gens qui sont
cachés derrière un écran j'ai déjà reçu
des mails de gens me disant je suis pas
d'accord avec vous mais le choix des
termes
sur cet exemple là le choix des termes
est monté d'un cran c'est ça que je
voulais dire je me suis quand même
implicitement fait traiter de nazis par
Luc Ferry dans le Figaro ce qui comme
disait Chirac toucher etc mais c'est un
sens je veux dire dans un endroit où on
les gaz c'est pas exactement comme
publier une règle de trois en expliquant
quels sont les conséquences
arithmétiques d'une limitation physique
sur les émissions voilà donc c'était ça
à l'origine c'est pas c'est pas du tout
encore une fois un truc que j'ai
travaillé depuis des années alors ce que
par contre au chiffre project on a quand
même travaillé depuis des années c'est
qu'on a regardé si en empilant toutes
les mesures techniques
l'hydrogène l'électricité les
carburantes substitution le progrès sur
les moteurs d'avion etc on pouvait avoir
un trafic aérien qui augmentait voir qui
restait identique à l'actuel enfin
l'actuel c'est précovide on va dire
parce que c'est à ce moment-là qu'on a
fait le travail avec juste des
innovations techniques et avoir le
secteur aérien qui prennent sa part dans
les accords de Paris c'est avoir des
émissions qui soient divisées par trois
ou quatre d'ici à 2050 et la réponse
c'est sans baisser le trafic on y arrive
pas donc ça c'est un rapport qui a été
fait par des ingénieurs de
l'aéronautique dans une association qui
s'appelle Aero des carbo c'est eux qui
ont fait et c'est des gens qui aiment la
vie même en tenant compte d'éventuels
progrès dans les techniques dont vous
parlez absolument ils en ont pas ils
n'ont pas tenu compte d'éventuels ils
ont tenu compte de progrès ils sont
allés de façon assez agressive dans la
pénétration de ces progrès donc à mon
avis ils sont en borne supérieure et
même très supérieure de ce qui sera
techniquement possible et il n'empêche
que la conclusion de leur travail est
quand même on a beau retourner le
problème dans tous les sens nous qui
aimons l'avion on voit pas comment on
arrive à avoir un secteur aérien qui se
décarbonne à la bonne vitesse sans que
le trafic ne baisse de quelques
pourcents par an alors ça c'est ça alors
que là au salon du Bourget les
différents spécialistes du secteur
expliquaient que le trafic allait
doubler dans les années je ne sais plus
quel était l'échelle mais enfin en gros
Air France prévoit par exemple de
doubler son angle c'est que vos
confrères en pareil cas quand ils
recueillent ce genre de déclaration ne
demande pas aux gens qu'ils les tiennent
d'aller immédiatement chez le notaire de
signer avec leur sang et sur leur
patrimoine qu'on va bien y arriver et
que si jamais on y arrive pas eux ou
leurs enfants sont immédiatement
dépossédés de tout ce qu'ils ont
d'accord et à ce moment est-ce qu'il
maintiennent leur affirmation je pense
qu'on aura quelques surprises c'est
évident que ça mange pas de pain de
prendre des positions pour un moment où
ils seront soit morts soit à la retraite
ou ailleurs et personne viendra les
rattraper à ce moment-là toute façon on
aura d'autres emmerdements plus
concrètement donc voilà donc c'est plus
concrètement ça veut dire que c'est des
affirmations qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas
payées Jean-Marc Jancovici en fait le
débat que vous avez soulevé est très
intéressant parce que on y voit ce
cogner justement tous les différents
intérêts et je peux même vous dire que
dans la rédaction de Marianne nous avons
eu des débats sur votre non pas donc pas
votre proposition mais votre affirmation
votre règle de trois
et que les journalistes de Marianne ne
sont pas d'accord entre eux pourquoi
parce que vous utilisez des chiffres
extrêmement froids extrêmement nettes
des chiffres qui reposent sur
l'observation du réel mais qui viennent
cogner la réalité des modes de vie des
aspirations des uns et des autres et qui
viennent cogner on en vient à nos
avionneurs qui viennent cogner des
intérêts aussi et en fait ce sont ces
trois éléments qui s'entrechoquent et
qui provoquent la violence dont vous
avez été l'objet par mail interposé
comment vous abordez ça c'est à dire que
si on présente aux gens uniquement des
chiffres froids est-ce qu'on peut
arriver à les faire changer dans leur
vision de ce qu'est un voyage en avion
et est-ce qu'on peut combattre les
intérêts je pense aux intérêts des
avionneurs je pense aux intérêts de ceux
qui vivent du touriste et on va vous
faire remarquer que dans les pays du Sud
beaucoup de pays vivent du tourisme et
en ont besoin pour se développer pour
que des gens sortent de la misère
comment on fait alors déjà il y a une
chose la première je vais commencer par
répondre à la première partie les
journalistes de Marianne sont pas
d'accord entre eux les jours les
journalistes de Marianne comme moi comme
vous sont des nantis au regard de ce
qu'est la condition humaine ordinaire
donc ils ont pris l'habitude de prendre
l'avion comme moi je prends le métro et
tout d'un coup on leur dit attention
petit rappel tout ça est basé sur le
pétrole qui n'est pas renouvelable et
créer un problème d'exutoire
c'est-à-dire que on en passe du CO2 dans
l'atmosphère de façon excessive c'est
pour ça que la part des décroissants
chez Mariannes partager votre votre
position peut en tout cas oui oui mais
c'est mais c'est normal la raison est
une des raisons je pense pour laquelle
j'ai vu cette collection de réactions
agressive c'est parce qu'en fait les
gens qui ont accès aux médias sont
globalement des nantis bien sûr voilà
donc ça les concerne directement eux
je pense que j'aurais fait cette
proposition dans une collection auprès
d'une collection de gens qui sont au RSA
je suis pas sûr j'aurais eu la même
réaction oui c'est ça il faut quand même
se souvenir que beaucoup de gens
prennent assez peu l'avion même si et
c'est tout le danger on va y venir mais
l'avion sait comme on dit démocratiser
et ce terme est très important le fait
d'utiliser ce terme démocratisé pour
dire qu'on a développé une industrie me
semble une manière un problème qui fait
que une fierté nationale moi le premier
quand j'étais jeune ingénieur et que
j'avais 25 ans je trouvais ça
merveilleux les avions enfin c'est
extraordinaire ce truc là c'est
quelque chose dont on peut être fier le
fait d'avoir localisé pour partie en
France et pour le reste en Europe
un concurrent de Boeing qui qui leur
donnait le pion quelque part il y a une
forme de fierté là-dedans que je partage
donc c'est pas le sujet donc c'est pas
parce que on a effectivement
objectivement des choses dont on peut se
dire on en est fier etc que ça que le
problème ne reste pas posé bon et dans
le secteur aérien il y a quand même
énormément de gens qui ont été dans le
déni très longtemps qui le sont à mon
avis encore aujourd'hui donc la première
échappatoire qu'ils ont trouvé c'est le
changement climatique n'existe pas je me
rappelle très rien à avoir fait une
conférence à super-héros il y a une
vingtaine d'années où je m'étais fait
voler dans les plumes par le responsable
Développement Durable d'Airbus qui
m'avait dit tout ça c'est des conneries
enfin il me l'avait pas dit comme ça
mais c'était ce qui c'est à peu près 6
disais on est sûr de rien etc ce qui
était quand même particulier farce dans
la mesure où les compétences qui sont
nécessaires pour faire voler des avions
la thermodynamique la mécanique c'est
exactement les mêmes que celles qui sont
nécessaires pour faire un modèle de
climat donc j'avais trouvé ça très très
drôle que cet homme là Vienne
m'expliquer que les chercheurs dans le
domaine de la climatologie racontait
n'importe quoi
et puis après ils sont passés comme
beaucoup de domaines qui ne voient pas
de solution évidentes dans un monde dans
lequel les émissions vont baisser
rapidement ils sont passés de le
problème et bien réel et en fait la
techno va faire le job donc en fait le
n'importe quoiisme il est passé de la
définition du problème où il reste
parfois vivace il y a un ancien mix la
Christian girondeau qui vient de sortir
un bouquin assez drôle enfin le titre
est assez drôle 30 ans de mensonges
donc de temps en temps il y a quand même
résurgence de ce genre de choses moins
quand même dans et en particulier dans
les élites le climato-scepticisme a
quand même largement disparu mais on est
passé sur le n'importe quoi tisme au
niveau de la solution donc en fait on va
y arriver sans aucun problème avec des
éoliennes des avions à hydrogène des
centrales nucléaires des machines etc et
puis tout ce que vous voulez et en gros
on peut dormir tranquille enfin le
consommateur peut dormir tranquille sur
ces deux oreilles
d'achat et les deux candidats à la
présidence du Medef peuvent dire tous
les deux que la techno va nous en sortir
dans un monde en croissance et que voilà
et en fait c'est c'est une autre forme
de déni c'est-à-dire que on accepte pas
l'idée que malheureusement quand on fait
les règles de 3 on voit pas comment on
s'en sort avec une consommation physique
qui baisse on voit pas alors vous allez
me dire donc du coup on le fait pas
parce que les gens ont pas envie parce
que les modestes parce que la misère
parce que les pays du Sud je sais pas
quoi et c'est là que je vous dis
malheureusement on va faire quand même
en gros on aura le choix que entre on
organise ça ou on le subit alors si on
subit ça s'appelle comment ça s'appelle
la déplétion pétrolière ça s'appelle la
déplétion des mines ça s'appelle etc
donc en gros les ressources qui
permettent de faire tourner l'économie
ça baisse on a fait un travail au
chiffre projet que montrant par exemple
que la quantité de pétrole qui serait
produite par les 16 premiers
fournisseurs de l'Europe qui sont par
ailleurs les 16 premiers producteurs
mondiaux or Brésil et Canada d'ici à
2050 elle va être divisée par deux leur
production ce qui veut dire que la
quantité de pétrole dont est issus de
kérosène rentrant en Europe va être
divisé par 2 à 10 ou 2 à 20 d'accord
parce que les exportations vont baisser
évidemment plus vite que la production
dans ces pays-là question on fait
comment si on est rattrapé par cette
patrouille là donc on aura dit ouais
ouais le climat on s'en veut
inventer des moteurs qui consomment
moins on va prendre des
biocarburants
à risquer toutes leurs économies sur sa
formation à partir du moment où on
répond oui je veux bien commencer à
discuter tant qu'il me répondent non
c'est qu'en fait ils savent très bien
que c'est une posture affective
émotionnelle c'est pas quelque chose de
fondé
donc là alors quand on regarde dans le
détail ce qu'on peut en faire en fait la
biomasse par exemple sur laquelle
beaucoup de gens comptent par exemple
pour faire des carburants d'origine
durable on se rend compte que tout le
monde compte dessus et qu'on n'a pas
fait de bouclage donc les gens qui font
des voitures compte dessus pour faire
rouler les voitures tant que le parc est
pas totalement électrique dès que vous
passez devant un champ de colza en
France et ses champs jaunes là en fait
dites-vous que c'est un truc qui va
finir dans un réservoir de voiture voilà
ça sert à ça essentiellement
donc la biomasse on en veut pour les
voitures on en veut pour l'énergie on va
faire des réseaux de chaleur des
centrales à bois etc on en veut pour la
construction donc il faut remplacer le
béton et l'acier par du bois on en veut
pour les fiches la paix ça s'appelle la
biodiversité on en veut pour les
carburants aériens et on en veut
accessoirement pour manger on a aussi
besoin et en fait quand vous faites la
somme de toutes les envies dans chaque
secteur qui ne sait pas confronté aux
autres secteurs vous vous retrouvez avec
quatre fois vous retrouvez quatre fois
ce qu'on va vraiment avoir donc comme on
va pas avoir 4 fois la surface terrestre
enfin la surface terrestre va pas être
multipliée par 4 le diamètre de la Terre
va pas bouger ça revient à dire que en
fait tous ces gens-là vont être déçus
et nous avec à partir du moment où il
compte sur quelque chose qui ne sera pas
là on en revient à la question de
l'établissement des priorités de la
façon dont on distribue le bien
disponible pour tous que ce soit le
nombre de vols en V n'en avion ou que ce
soit du biocarburant quand on a par
exemple Elisabeth borne qui répond je ne
sais pas dans quel monde on a envie de
vivre je ne sais pas si les jeunes ont
envie de vivre dans un monde où on a son
quota de billets d'avion et quelqu'un
qui vous surveille je ne suis pas sûr
que ce soit formidable comme modèle
c'est-à-dire qu'on en vient à cette
question cruciale comme moi c'est dans
un monde où on n'a pas de problème oui
mais comment on règle démocratiquement
ça en fait c'est une question
extrêmement concrète comment on
distribue d'où le fait que vous utilisez
que vous utilisiez le terme modèle
communiste qui décide de quelle manière
comment on partage parce que juste une
chose quand on vous écoute dire en fait
mon calcul je l'ai fait en fonction de
différentes choses si tout le monde sur
la planète prenait l'avion je sais que
les gens qui vous écoutent se disent
dans leur petite tête oui mais pour
l'instant un éthiopien un soudanais un
moins besoin que nous de prendre l'avion
donc ça va s'équilibrer petit à petit
donc pour l'instant on est tranquille
c'est ça qui se passe en fait absolument
alors même si on restait avec les
inégalités d'accès à l'avion
d'aujourd'hui de toute façon il faut
baisser les émissions de 5 % par an donc
toutes choses égales par ailleurs il
faut baisser les vols des Français de 5%
par an ou si on reste avec la même
répartition dans le monde tout le monde
baisse ces vols de 5% par an voilà c'est
la même 5% je pense que beaucoup ça
c'est faisable bah c'est divisé par 3
d'ici à 2050
en 1950 il y avait pas ça en France les
gens faisaient pas 4 ans
donc ça veut dire que vous il faut
réfléchir une fois qu'on dit ça il faut
réfléchir à la façon dont on organise
l'économie et la vie des gens il faut
bien comprendre que le 20e siècle ça
s'appelle le pétrole c'est je n'ai pas
eu le pétrole il y aurait pas eu le 20e
siècle on serait pas dans ce fauteuil
tous les deux on serait occupé à faire
autre chose visser des boulons à
ramasser des patates qu'est-ce que je
sais mais le 20e siècle n'existerait pas
je serai en train de faire le ménage
dans une maison puisque c'est aussi
c'est aussi le progrès du Triel qui a
libéré les femmes de cet âge-là vous
avez reçu l'autrice de ce livre que j'ai
trouvé très intéressant sur la question
donc la la pour en venir à ce que je
disais ce qu'on a fait depuis deux
siècles c'est oublier la contrainte
physique en gros depuis deux siècles
l'énergie abondante nous a repoussé les
limites en permanence donc nous n'avons
pas la mémoire nos parents non plus nos
grands-parents non plus nos arrières
grands-parents non plus d'un monde
stable nous n'avons que la mémoire d'un
monde en expansion donc c'est normal que
on se dise comment on fait pour gérer un
monde stable ou un monde en contraction
parce que en fait on n'a pas de réflexe
on a on n'a pas de bagages intellectuels
économistes n'ont pas de bagages
intellectuels pour ça par exemple ils
ont pas de boîte à outils pour ça ils
ont qu'une boîte à outils pour gérer un
monde en expansion
donc comme on est vous savez
Maxime Shadok pas de solution pas de
problème donc c'est exactement ça qui
est en train de s'appliquer en ce moment
alors pour en revenir à la question du
choix démocratique j'ai pas de réponse
évidente à votre question quand je
disais je suis favorable un système
communiste en fait c'était une blague
évidemment ça veut dire juste dire que
entre la régulation par les prix et la
régulation par les quantités je trouve
que la régulation par les quantités est
plus équitable voilà dit autrement si on
régule par les prix
c'est un système régressif donc en fait
c'est comme quand vous mettez une taxe
indirecte ça ne s'agène moins les gens
qu'on beaucoup d'argent que les gens qui
n'ont moins c'est absolument évident
c'est pas dire qu'il faut pas le faire
de temps en temps mais c'est quand même
ça la réalité
le système de quota c'est un système
dans lequel c'est un différents revenus
donc c'est un système qui est
globalement plus égalitaire voilà
donc si je sais pas si je prends l'accès
à l'hôpital par exemple il est pas
régulé par vos revenus il est régulé par
la capacité de l'hôpital à faire des
opérations à vous prendre aux urgences
etc donc c'est un système de type quota
on a on a des quotas de temps des quotas
d'opération des noms de trucs qu'on peut
faire et on affecte pas ça en fonction
des revenus bon enfin en théorie donc
c'est voilà donc c'est voilà donc c'est
ça que j'appelle moi un système
communiste entre guillemets et
personnellement ça a plutôt ma
préférence je pense que ça c'est plus
acceptable oui ça nécessite un travail
de réorganisation complète de la société
puisque on va vous faire valoir qu'il y
a des secteurs des gens qui ont besoin
de prendre l'avion et ça rejoint une
autre question puisque en fait cette
réorganisation de la société il faut la
faire dans tous les domaines si on prend
par exemple la réduction du bilan
carbone des industries lourdes ce qui
est un élément essentiel et si on prend
par exemple parmi ces industrie lourde
celle du béton qui est quand même non
seulement en bilan carbone mais en
destruction des fonds marins quelque
chose d'absolument effarant ça nécessite
de réorganiser notre vision de ce que
c'est que le logement or on voit qu'il y
a une crise du logement en France donc
notre vision de certaines règles sur qui
qui peut construire comment pour dans
quel but comment on fait encore une fois
vous voyez c'est ce sont c'est un
changement d'une ampleur énorme alors il
faut bien voir que pour gérer la société
en expansion on a deux siècles
d'héritage intellectuels accumulés donc
le comment on fait on va pas le faire en
un claquement de doigts en 3 minutes
dans ce fauteuil la première réponse est
la seule que je peux vous faire c'est il
faut déjà y réfléchir aujourd'hui on ne
le fait pas on continue partout à
réfléchir dans un monde en expansion en
fait il faut bien comprendre que par
delà les discours politiques ou de temps
en temps on appelle à la sobriété la
réalité du quotidien des fonctionnaires
et des sociétés du privé c'est de
réfléchir avec des outils qui sont faits
pour un monde en expansion c'est ça la
réalité du quotidien prenons l'exemple
des infrastructure routière aujourd'hui
quand vous faites le bilan
socio-économique d'une infrastructure
routière pour décider ou pas de la
construire les règles de calcul sont
celles d'un monde en expansion elles
sont pas celles d'un monde stable ou en
contraction donc vous pouvez dire par
exemple les l'idée de l'autoroute a69
absolument 12 Castres ça part du
principe qu'il faut
développer un territoire
du principe qu'il y aura de plus en plus
de Jobs qui seront de plus en plus payés
que etc c'est peut-être pas ça qu'on va
avoir donc si c'est pas ça qu'on a
est-ce que c'est toujours pertinent de
faire cet autoroute ça part du principe
qui aura de plus en plus de gens comme
on les moyens de se payer une voiture si
c'est pas ça est-ce qu'il faut toujours
faire une autoroute oui c'est ça que ce
que je dis bon
donc je suis peut-être pas en train de
dire des choses très sympathiques mais
en attendant si on est
dirigeant que ce soit dans le secteur
public ou dans le secteur privé on n'est
pas payé juste pour s'intéresser à des
éventualités sympathiques on est payé
pour s'intéresser à ce qui peut se
produire sympathique moins sympathique
bon quand vous organisez un système
hospitalier vous vous intéressez à des
éventualités pas sympathiques du tout
puisque vous intéressez au fait que les
gens vont tomber malade vont avoir des
problèmes etc personne n'a envie de
tomber malade pourtant on organise quand
même un système en fonction de ça donc
il y a besoin aujourd'hui d'avoir de
façon beaucoup plus large dans la
société la réflexion opérationnelle il
s'agit pas juste de manier des concepts
philosophiques la réflexion
opérationnelle sur comment est-ce qu'on
fait pour gérer une société dans
laquelle les ressources physiques sont
de moins en moins disponibles et non pas
de plus en plus disponibles il y a toute
une école de pensée à inventer là-dessus
alors j'y project on essaye d'apporter
très modestement notre part et on a
commencé c'est ce qu'on a fait avec le
plan de transformation de l'économie
française à essayer de réfléchir à
comment est-ce qu'on réorganise les flux
physique de l'économie
ce qu'on produit en mètres carrés en
tonnes en litres etc et les compétences
c'est à ce qui demande du temps pour
être changé personne qui est en train de
me filmer par exemple deviendra pas
menuisier du jour au lendemain si jamais
c'est ça que la société demande voilà
donc il y a quand même sur la question
des compétences c'est un truc qui est
crucial très souvent négligé dans les
politiques publiques on est on néglige
le temps qu'il faut pour former des gens
pour leur faire faire un autre métier
mais il faut donc on a réfléchi à ça
dans le plan de transformation de
l'économie française et on a commencé à
poser quelques bases quelques
suggestions sur la façon d'avancer dans
cette direction on peut en venir au
logement par exemple et au béton dans
les propositions qu'on a faites et qui
font aussi sauter les gens en l'air on a
constaté qu'actuellement il y avait deux
fois plus de logements en construit
chaque année que de création de nouveaux
ménages donc la crise du logement n'est
peut-être pas dû que
à un sujet de nombre de gens allongés
elle est due au lieu où on est obligé
exactement des logements
des emplois dans les endroits où il y a
déjà du bâti ça nécessite de faire de
l'aménagement du territoire les
retraités éventuellement qui ont les
moyens de parler de faire construire une
maison au bord de l'eau et de enfin il y
a plein de trucs que ça nécessite de
faire et on en revient toujours à la
même question qui est comment est-ce
qu'on décide collectivement d'une
contrainte
alors il y a que deux manières de faire
ça
la première c'est on reste dans une
démocratie représentative et on accepte
que en notre nom les gens qu'on a élu au
Parlement et la personne qu'on a élu à
l'Élysée le décide pour nous c'est quand
même ça la base justement dans ce
cadre-là il faut que les citoyens et
l'impression que les représentants les
représentent vraiment et ne sont pas
soumis à la pression de lobby qui eux
vont défendre des intérêts c'est ce
qu'on voit dans tous les conflits
environnementaux aujourd'hui c'est que
vous avez des gens qui basculent dans la
violence et parfois dans une violence
inadmissible mais en même temps si on a
l'impression que des lobbies empêchent
de faire avancer les choses le blocage
est tel que vous favorisez cette
violence il faut relire Tocqueville les
lobbys sont consubstantiels à la
démocratie vous avez pas de démocratie
sans lobby c'est-à-dire 100 personnes
tentant de faire valoir leurs intérêts
auprès des représentants de la nation
c'est c'est inévitable et l'Union des
industries chimiques est tout autant à
Lomé Greenpeace d'accord donc les deux
sont organisés même le chiffre Project
vous pouvez mettre dans la catégorie des
lobbys c'est-à-dire c'est une structure
qui tente de faire valoir ses intérêts
ou plus exactement qui tentent de faire
valoir des positions dans le débat
public les positions oui mais ça
ressemble je suis d'accord c'est un
fonctionne de la même manière et en
effet les ONG sont aussi des lobbies
après la question est de savoir quelle
cause ont défend et qu'elle ne peut pas
mettre de l'huile dans les rouages pour
que ça marche mieux il y a une huile qui
se met dans les rouages qui s'appelle de
la formation c'est à dire que on gère
beaucoup plus mal un problème qu'on n'a
pas compris qu'un problème qu'on a bien
compris raison pour laquelle votre
serviteur intervalle régulier explique
que ça serait quand même bien que les
gens qui nous gouvernent comprennent un
peu de quoi il retourne
il y a une initiative du reste heureuse
qui a insuffisante qui a été mise en
place par le gouvernement actuel sur la
formation des hauts fonctionnaires alors
en fait pour le moment on est plus
proche de la sensibilisation que de la
formation ils ont quand même une fresque
du climat donc ils commencent quand même
à toucher un peu du doigt le sujet
climatique mais il n'y a pas la partie
ressource il y a pas la partie
biodiversité il y a pas etc et puis
derrière il faut surtout mettre en place
des outils opérationnels c'est-à-dire je
suis à la Direction des Routes
opérationnellement comment est-ce que
j'incorpore ce problème dans la façon
que j'ai de décider de la rénovation ou
pas de l'extension ou pas du réseau
routier de sa transformation ou pas etc
et aujourd'hui ces outils là ils
n'existent pas d'accord donc formation
c'est créer ces outils et les déployer
il y a un sujet de dialogue via les
corps intermédiaires donc il y a un
sujet de syndicat d'association de etc
d'associations Medef comme CLCV donc
d'un côté comme de l'autre et là aussi
il y a un sujet à la fois de formation
et de réflexion interne sur comment
est-ce que hiérarchise mes priorités en
tenant compte d'une nouvelle contrainte
il y a éventuellement des initiatives de
type conférence des citoyens dont la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
était
on peut penser éventuellement au
référendum et dans ce pays c'est
toujours un exercice piéger parce que la
culture des Français fait que c'est pas
comment Suisse quand on pose une
question il répond presque autant à la
personne qui a posé la question qu'à la
question elle-même justement parce qu'il
y en a pas assez souvent peut-être je ne
sais pas la démocratie c'est enfin c'est
une culture absolument peut-être qu'il
faut commencer par faire ce genre de
choses au niveau local pour voir comment
ça se passe donc au niveau d'un
département d'une région etc ce qu'on ne
fait que très peu aujourd'hui ce qu'on
avait fait sur Notre-Dame-des-Landes
mais sans doute mal fait c'est à dire
que
c'était pas à l'échelle voilà la
définition du périmètre de consultation
et ne correspondait pas à la
problématique posée
au secteur aérien la nuisance est
globale il n'y a pas que de la nuisance
locale il n'y a pas que du bruit et du
trafic routier il y a d'autres trucs il
y a des gaz à effet de serre c'est
climat global etc donc la question du
périmètre de la consultation était
clairement posé une question pour pour
ce qui me concerne pas du tout une
réponse je m'étais fait la réflexion
dans un livre que j'avais écrit il y a
quelques années que la démocratie était
née dans un monde en croissance
c'est-à-dire que en Europe
philosophiquement c'est lié en fait le
premier problème
qui est aussi le premier pays à avoir
tapé dans ces stocks de charbon et avoir
démarré une croissance industrielle et
les pays qui ont suivi derrière et je ne
connais pas d'exemple aujourd'hui de
démocratie durablement installée dans la
contraction physique et la démocratie
athénienne elle s'appuie sur les sur
l'esclavage et ne peut exister que par
l'esclavage même si ce n'est pas une
philosophie de la croissance on est
d'accord mais en fait c'est c'est
exactement ce qu'on a reproduit
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que la
démocratie athénienne ou romaine c'était
une poignée de nanties assis sur une
armée d'esclaves c'est exactement ce
qu'on a reproduit aujourd'hui une
poignée alors quelques milliards quand
même de nanti assis sur une armée
d'esclaves qui sont pas les habitants
des pays du Sud qui sont les machines
donc en fait on a créé une poignée de
lentilles de milliards de personnes
allaient assis sur l'équivalent de 400
milliards d'esclaves mécaniques voilà
c'est exactement ça qu'on a reproduit
oui ceci près que l'esclavage des
machines pose moralement moins de
problèmes que l'esclavage des êtres
humains
mais en fait le fait que ces machines
consomment des combustibles fossiles
comment ça poser un problème moral donc
on est en train de retrouver à mon avis
il y a un historien il s'appelle
Jean-François Moreau qui avait écrit un
petit bouquin que j'avais préférée du
reste il y a quelques années que ça peut
être des esclaves énergétiques oui oui
suivez ce parallèle justement entre le
vrai esclavage et l'esclavage des
machines enfin le fait qu'on ait des
esclaves mécaniques et il disait que le
parallèle Mor il pouvait quand même se
voir et que on allait peut-être la voir
de façon de plus en plus aiguë et
peut-être surtout que le la
transformation des citoyens en
consommateur facilitent leur façon de ne
pas percevoir ou de ne pas vouloir voir
ce qu'est l'esclavage parce que de
l'esclavage moderne on en refabrique
aussi par exemple avec les
uber eats deliveroo et autres choses
comme ça ou c'est du véritable esclavage
d'individus ce qui veut dire que
l'augmentation des facilités de
consommation un site l'être humain à ne
pas être responsable de ses actions
alors moi je dirais plutôt que c'est
dans l'autre sens que c'est en train de
se produire il faut savoir qu'en France
l'apogée est dans toute la zone au CDE
l'apogée de la consommation énergétique
globale de la zone c'est 2008 c'est le
pic de production du pétrole
conventionnel qui a dans ma vision des
choses directement déclenchée la crise
financière de l'époque c'est-à-dire
quand on regarde l'enchaînement il y a
eu d'abord moins d'énergie puis une
économie qui a décélérer puis la crise
financière et les mêmes causes vont
reproduire les mêmes effets c'est juste
une question de temps
ce qui s'est passé depuis c'est que du
coup moins de machines par personne
aisément accessible on remis en selle
des emplois peu qualifiés
dans un contexte restez libéral et
rester non protecteur on va dire et à ce
moment on fabrique effectivement des
gens qui sont alors quand même pas des
esclaves mais qui sont des gens qui ont
des conditions on va dire moins
sympathiques que les gens qui qui les
ont c'est moins sympathique c'est pas
des esclaves c'est quand même des gens
qui sont des citoyens libres ils ont le
droit de vote ils ont pas des esclaves
encore une fois les montsens
qui n'ont pas de papier qui n'ont pas de
statut et qui n'ont aucune protection
enfin quand je dis deliveroo pas tout ce
fonctionnement
mais ils sont évidemment c'est à
l'évidence beaucoup moins bien traité
que le salarié d'une société ordinaire
ou que un fonctionnaire donc c'est
absolument évident
donc je et c'est un risque que j'avais
identifié à l'époque où j'avais constaté
tu vois en écrivant ce bouquin que
c'était il y avait une concordance entre
l'abondance énergétique et le
basculement dans la démocratie je
m'étais dit du coup il y a un vrai
risque pour les libertés dans un monde
qui est en décrue énergétique et qui ne
s'occupe pas du problème et qui
n'anticipe pas le problème le risque
c'est de retrouver de la brutalité dans
les rapports humains et donc ce qu'on
risque mais est-ce que les défenseurs de
l'économie malheureusement si on n'y
prend pas garde mais est-ce que les
défenseurs de l'écologie sont toujours
eux des démocrates aussi c'est à dire
qu'on a une augmentation de la brutalité
des rapports humains et parallèlement on
a un discours qui consiste à dire face à
un enjeu qui est un enjeu vital il y a
certaines libertés qu'on peut se
permettre de suspendre on est perdant
des deux côtés non alors ça dépend qui
vous appelez les défenseurs de
l'écologie si on pense à l'écologie
politique historique je vais prononcer
un mot qui va pas leur faire plaisir
mais je les terriblement naïf je les
trouve naïf et parcellaire naïf parce
que il s'imagine il suffit de regarder
l'histoire pour se dire que la décrue
des ressources ça va pas juste être un
truc simple à gérer il y a qu'à faucon
et qu'est-ce qu'on attend pour ça pose
un milliard de problèmes sociaux
d'organisation d'aménagement du
territoire etc prenons l'aménagement du
territoire on a mis deux siècles à faire
un pays urbanisé dépendant des camions
pour se nourrir dépendant de
l'agriculture intensive pour se nourrir
etc est-ce qu'on va changer ça en une
semaine pas une seconde comment est-ce
que on fait pour réaménager le
territoire avec beaucoup plus de monde à
la campagne et beaucoup moins de monde
en ville c'est une modification profonde
des emplois c'est pas juste il y a qu'à
faucon est-ce que tous les gens qui sont
en ville dans un bureau où le cul dans
un canapé comme nous sont prêts à
retourner biner la terre je ne sais pas
en tout cas c'est pas aussi simple que
ça est-ce qu'on est prêt à assumer la
conséquence évidente avec le système
économique qu'on a si on fait ça à que
le prix de la nourriture augmente je ne
sais pas donc en fait il y a des il y a
des tas de questions qui se posent
aujourd'hui pour lesquelles on en
revient à la question du débat
démocratique là-dessus un débat
démocratique ça s'instruit c'est à dire
que dire aux gens est-ce que vous êtes
pour ou contre si on n'a pas instruit le
dossier à l'avance on en sorte du
gloubi-boulga rien d'exploitable la
délibération et ça c'est le rôle de la
techno structure sous-jacente aussi
instruire instruire les dossiers
c'est-à-dire que il faut des gens pour
faire des calculs poser des questions
faire des hypothèses faire des
suggestions regarder les éventualités
etc c'est l'affaire je le redis des
corps intermédiaires c'est l'affaire des
acteurs économiques c'est l'affaire de
la fonction publique c'est l'affaire des
élus c'est l'affaire de tout le monde
quelque part d'instruire les dossiers et
les médias ils sont là pour relayer les
éléments d'instruction ils vont pas les
créer parce que ils sont ils ont pas
c'est pas des Sting tanks c'est pas des
labos c'est pas des bons
déjà quand ils le relèvent bien c'est
bien bon et cette affaire là elle est
elle est pas triviale du tout bon et on
rend un mauvais service à la
collectivité en présentant ses débats
comme des débats triviaux dans lesquels
il y a des solutions évidentes à
appliquer et il y a des abrutis pour pas
le faire c'est évidemment beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça et tous autant que nous
sommes nous sommes des tissus de
contradiction tous autant que nous
sommes bon on est on est piloté par nos
affects beaucoup plus que par notre
rationalité c'est c'est c'est absolument
évident tous même les scientifiques même
les ingénieurs les gens comme moi tous
donc la question de savoir comment
est-ce qu'on organise tout ça est une
question protéiforme extrêmement
complexe
et l'écologie politique historique a été
globalement elle est pertinente pour
lancer des signals d'alarme aujourd'hui
je maintiens qu'elle est malheureusement
sur beaucoup de sujets alors c'est en
train de changer mais elle est
malheureusement sur beaucoup de sujets
très loin de la balle en ce qui concerne
la maturité des solutions proposées
voilà je pense qu'il y a encore une
beaucoup trop de naïvetés et c'est la
raison du reste pour laquelle le
dialogue avec les autres parties
prenantes et crisper parfois simpliste
parfois etc donc il y a besoin aussi du
côté des gens qui veulent défendre
l'environnement besoin de travailler
c'est à dire de peser sous peser
pour ça pour des moyens tout à fait
d'accord mais il y a aussi ce besoin là
alors c'est en train de venir notamment
dans le monde associatif on commence à
trouver dans le monde associatif des
organismes qui se professionnalisme qui
montent en gamme qui est etc
et qui sont capables de faire du travail
technique de qualité qui contribue très
utilement au débat
au sein des partis politiques pour le
moment ils sont encore un peu en retard
par rapport à ça
aussi ce que j'entends et ce sera
peut-être la conclusion de cette
discussion c'est qu'il y a encore
énormément de travail extrêmement précis
de la part de tous et que mine de rien
pendant ce temps-là on ne change rien
mais on va rester sur la vous êtes
souvent pessimiste on va rester sur la
face positive que il y a quand même du
progrès on va devoir avancer en marchant
comme dirait l'autre c'est à dire qu'il
y a des domaines dans lesquels on a déjà
les grandes lignes on peut commencer à
avancer en fait on est dans un on est
dans un brouillard inégal en fonction
des sujets il y a des sujets pour
lesquels on a déjà des idées
raisonnablement simples
alors je vais prendre l'exemple de la
mobilité la mobilité en fait le cocktail
qu'il faut mettre en oeuvre on leur a à
peu près en tête il faut au moins une
voiture les électrifier plus de vélo sur
toutes les formes vélo électrique vélo
cargo etc modifier les infrastructures
donc il faut que le BTP arrête de faire
des ronds et des autoroutes et fasse des
pistes cyclables
très bien si on leur demande de faire ça
il faut des infrastructures qu'il y a
avec des parkings à vélo etc il faut
électrifier le fret
dans le domaine de la mobilité par
exemple les solutions techniques
l'architecture d'ensemble etc la façon
dont il faut s'y prendre à urbanisme
constant et puis après de toute façon ça
peut suivre la modification de
l'organisme c'est beaucoup plus clair
par exemple que comment est-ce que on
modifie le dialogue social dans un monde
dans lequel on a un conflit croissant
entre consommation et environnement par
exemple donc je dis pas qu'on peut rien
faire ce que je dis c'est que il faut à
la fois commencer à avancer là où on
commence à avoir des idées claires et
puis dans le même temps investir
considérablement plus de moyens
intellectuels dans la façon de
construire quelque chose d'un peu
cohérent
parce que pour finir sur la démocratie
c'est quand même plus facile aux gens
quels qu'ils soient d'accepter un
ensemble cohérent dans lequel il voit où
ils sont eux
que d'accepter un slogan je veux dire un
slogan on comprend pas où on en est
alors pour finir par où on a commencé
dans dans le résultat du calcul 4 volts
dans une vie les gens voient très bien
où ils sont eux d'accord là en
l'occurrence à les chatouiller un peu
mais il voit très bien où ils sont
alors ça c'est la partie j'ai envie de
dire punitive ou coercitive ou etc il y
a aussi des tas de parties où on peut
leur montrer où ils sont eux qui sont
plus positifs par exemple les emplois
qui vont être nécessaires dans le cadre
du plan de transformation de l'économie
française on a eu des dialogues très
intéressants avec les syndicats on a
commencé à discuter encore une fois dans
des trucs qui me paraît totalement
crucial dans cette histoire c'est
comment on traite les perdants comment
on organise la mutation de l'emploi
comme on organise la mutation des
compétences etc vraiment un truc central
et on sait pas du tout fait accueillir
un coup de tomates pourries c'est il y a
eu il y a eu un
dialogue insuffisant mais qui a commencé
à se nouer qui est intéressant et c'est
évident que c'est d'autant plus facile
aux gens d'accepter une construction
collective dans laquelle ils vont devoir
faire des efforts si
identifient clairement un le bénéfice
qu'on en retire et il faut rappeler que
dans les bénéfices essentiels il y a la
paix et la stabilité et on l'oublie
parce que en ligne de pente on va perdre
tout ça bon mesure pas bien ce que ça
veut dire mais je pense quand même que
c'est et la deuxième chose qu'on peut y
gagner c'est des projets collectifs une
forme de fierté à avoir fait des choses
un emploi dont on voit une forme de
pérennité une utilité sociale les gens
sont sensibles au fait d'avoir une
utilité sociale c'est évident sinon il y
aura pas d'infirmière donc voilà donc je
pense que on a on a un certain nombre de
choses et il faut réfléchir avec les
atouts qu'on peut en retirer et les
efforts qu'on va devoir faire
merci beaucoup Jean-Marc francovici on a
tiré quelques fils je pense qu'il faudra
reprendre cette discussion pour aller
plus loin sur tout cela merci encore
[Musique]